[Aplausos]
eu sempre considerada uma menina feia
pelo menos por mim ou pela maioria das
pessoas à minha volta
meus pais no caso dos únicos que
realmente apreciavam essa beleza
singular
a van apesar de de sempre ter tido uma
autoestima muito baixa como toda criança
negra com a cidade
existe um grupo específico de pessoas
que me tratava de uma forma diferente
com a cidade
existe um grupo de pessoas que de fato
sabia que ela era uma menina não muito
bonita mesmo desajeitado desengonçada
mas que também sabiam que de alguma
forma eu me tornaria uma mulher muito
bonita quando crescesse
esse grupo de pessoas era formado
majoritariamente por homens homens mais
velhas
geralmente primos de segundo grau amigos
e primos de segundo grau ou então
desconhecidos quando estavam na rua com
meu pai atrás de um balcão roubando
dinheiro de troco do almoço falavam pra
ele
nossa a sua filha linda vai dar muito
trabalho quando crescer vai ter um monte
de gavião e ria 89 anos eu tinha eu
ficava me perguntando o que faz o que
fez com que homens como aquele atrás do
balcão e com que tantos outros homens
enxergassem em uma criança de 8 9 anos
alguma possibilidade de beleza como eles
entendiam que de alguma forma daria
trabalho trabalho como eles entendiam
que de alguma forma eu teria
pretendentes como eles entendiam que uma
menina que não se esforçava em nada para
ser sensual para ser bonita que não
sabia sobre maquiagem que não sabia
sobre decote que era só uma criança como
eles sabiam que essa criança feia daria
trabalho
essa foi uma das perguntas que eu sempre
fiz ao longo da minha vida porque eu me
vejo feia porque as pessoas me vencer
mas porque existe uma parcela masculina
que tem certeza que eu sei bonita de
onde saiu isso
eu comecei a me perguntar e eu passei a
deixar de me questionar porque é uma
pessoa
eu me sentia feia então era melhor
alguém falar na tv você é feia mas você
pode tornar bonita do que alguém fala
mal de você vai ser sempre cheia
foi com 11 12 anos que eu entendi o que
eu era eu entendi que era mulata é
impedir que as pessoas me tratavam e me
viam como a mulata o que era a mulata
naquela época naquela época pra mim
mulata é uma categoria menos pior de
negra
as pessoas falavam nada de você é feia
pra caramba
nem realizando o seu cabelo muito jeito
sorte sua que matam preta eu ergui as
mãos pro céu e falava
sorte minha que eu não sou tão preta
deus não me fez branca me entristece por
isso mas obrigado por ter me feito
mulata é um sofrimento - com os meus 14
e 15 anos por aí 13 14 anos eu comecei a
entender o que a mídia ea sociedade
dizia sobre o que era mulata eu comecei
a entender que ser mulata é tão ruim que
simulará ter a ser da cor do pecado que
celular para ter curvas envolvente
sensuais que a mulata me colocava na
poesia que a mulata colocava o meu corpo
na bossa nova eu não era a mulata mas eu
me tornaria a mulata e era expectativa
de que meu corpo se desenvolvesse que as
curvas aparecer sim eu pudesse enfim ser
a mulher que sambava fazer com que
recebi é receber elogios
esses eram os únicos eu aceitei me
chamavam de mulata sabe mulata de mula
que é um híbrido de cavalo e jumento que
foi um termo cunhado no passado colonial
da classificar os filhos feitos dos
estupros cometidos pelos donos das casas
grandes nós negros escravizados e que
hoje em dia é um termo racista que
caracteriza mulheres negras de pele
clara magras
porém coelhinhas e com certeza por uma
determinação biológicas a bênção da a
final
faltar no sangue sabe sambar com 15 e 16
com de 67 anos estrangulado a academia
lata falarem uma vida inteira que a
mulata chegar até aqui esperando essa
mulata aqui no ensino médio que ele
pegou beber
as pessoas precisam achar que sou bonita
de alguma forma o único elogio que eu
vivi vida inteira que eu seria bonita no
dia que meu corpo se desenvolver se
efetivasse a mulata então cadê a mulata
eu esperei a mulata é a mulata não foi
aparecendo ao lado não vinha eu ficava
preocupada minhas amigas feitos com
dúvidas e ainda reta eu falava cadê essa
bola dessa mulata que me prometeram a
vida inteira
cadê a minha auto-estima estaria com ela
cada um único a única expectativa de
amor próprio
eu coloquei dentro de uma bunda de um
peito me prometeram durante toda a minha
vida vai ser muito bonita ela vai ser um
bar
ela vai rebolar ela vai ter um corpo de
dar inveja porque ela é uma mulata e
mulata é menos pior
eu esperei mulata a moda não apareceu e
aqui tá e hoje
meu corpo para se desenvolver aos 13
anos com 13 anos e nunca se mais eu não
estou fisicamente então com 13 anos eu
comecei a entrar em pânico com 15 anos
estava desesperada e eu comecei a
perceber que de fato a mulata não
chegaria e que eu precisaria compreender
e achar outras formas de lidar com o meu
corpo conta 78 anos eu passei o dia o
meu corpo porque ela não veio
então não tinha nada que me salvasse não
tinha expectativas de melhoras
eu já vi o meu corpo muito eu odiava
quem não é de uma forma muito profunda
ponto de bater em noites de crise quando
estava mal aponta desvio rat os meus
próprios seios porque eles não cresceram
o tanto que as pessoas dizem que ele
deveria ter crescido com 17 18 anos eu
passei por um período do dia o meu corpo
onde o meu corpo magro
esse corpo de um corpo magro como eu um
adolescente então dentro do meu tempo é
um fruto da minha época queria revistas
femininas que via tv desde a novela que
sabe que o ideal era o corpo magro como
eu consegui o dia o meu corpo magro como
conseguir um corpo era padronizada como
conseguir um corpo que era valorizado
como conseguiu dar um corpo que em todos
os passos diziam que era melhor eu
odiava o meu corpo magro e porque seria
porque os mecanismos do racismo são
muito mais complexos e muito mais
profundos porque qualquer padrão de
beleza
será que por eu odeio meu corpo magro
porque de alguma forma o fato de ter
inferiorizado pessoas por conta de seus
traços e de suas origens culturais
valesse ao longo da história valeu valeu
mais do que padrões de beleza que se
transforma ao longo do tempo será que é
isso será que de fato é uma coisa séria
será que racismo de fato é estrutural
não é conjuntura será que a reação da
sociedade muito mais profundamente do
que a gente compreende que a central
ainda não acabou ser acrescenta ainda
o que será que a senzala
quando a gente acha um menino negro na
rua e se assusta com ele
será que a senzala quanto menos pressa
uma pessoa que eu sou será que és em
sala quando você se surpreendem ao
perceber que nós mulheres negras somos
inteligentes será que a senzala
quando você se surpreende por eu estar
aqui falando para vocês será que as
instala quando eu me surpreendo por
estar aqui falando para vocês
será que ainda não está em mim será que
não está em vocês
será que a gente superou existem
mulheres que a mulata chega e quando ela
está cheia o que acontece quando a bunda
chega quando o peito cheio o que
acontece com as mulheres
elas pedem da nunca ter nascido porque
elas não suportam a forma como são
tratadas por que ela não se ela não
suporta uma forma como são objetificadas
o tempo inteiro em todas as suas
relações em todos os seus espaços quando
ela chega é insuportável porque elas não
conseguem andar na rua porque elas não
conseguem conversar com pessoas sem
sentir o desconforto dos olhares das
piadas retomada aos seus corpos
quando a bola chega essas mulheres pedem
a deus deus por que me fez mulata e eu
pedi pra deus porque não me façam lata
então com a diferença a diferença é que
haja uma estrutura e ele vai fazer com
que você odeia com que você odeia seu
corpo a sua vida às suas origens
independente de quem você seja basta ser
negro
você pode ser mais você pode ser gordo
você pode ser rico você pode ser pobre
você pode ser intelectual você pode ser
analfabeto
assim dá até pra todo mundo de maneira
talvez mais intensa para uns do que para
outros mas ela tá aqui
assim exatamente a senzala
quando eu dei meu corpo quando eu dei a
minha realidade
quando eu odeio quem eu sou corresponde
ao estereótipo de beleza dessa sociedade
que a bancada atual
o racismo não mata
na entrada ele faz com que você quer
morrer na saída o racismo destrói de
maneira
área descarada negra de perda de bilhete
quinta preta escura
o artigo fala meu nome como forma de
amor ele fala mulata bonita sensual e
depois esfaqueou pelas costas para
fazendo augusto dos anjos o racismo e
escarra na minha boca enquanto me beija
a gente não senhor de engenho a gente
não precisa de chibatadas brutal nossos
corpos porque assim além de aqui nas
nossas mentes de maneira virtual não
corpórea
enquanto a gente tiver pessoas negras
que se sentem subjugados por serem quem
são
enquanto nós tivermos pessoas negras que
não sentem pertencentes não sempre
valorosos por ter intenção enquanto não
enquanto eu ainda hoje era um corpo que
nunca me fez nada porque a sociedade diz
que eu devo odiah enquanto eu achar que
a única coisa que me valoriza
é um ideal racista imposto sobre mim
quando o meu corpo ainda nem havia se
desenvolvido enquanto isso acontecer
assim além de aqui
assim além de agora ea chibata mesmo que
de maneira muito silenciosa continuam
aceitando as nossas mentes
obrigada
[Aplausos]